[Music]
hello I'm Greg Sandler the president and
co-founder of reason am I'd like to tell
you about something exciting that we've
got coming up in this month of April
2017 the second of our sequence of free
online webinars and more intensive
online seminars last month we did
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics books 2
through 4 discussing the nature of
virtues and vices this month were
zeroing in on books 8 through 9 again in
the Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics and
for those of you who have studied that
you know what that means
friendship we're gonna talk about the
three main kinds of friendship about
unequal friendships about what equalizes
them about family relations about
politics we're also going to get into
some of the nitty-gritty about you know
when friends ought to break off the
friendship or when it's okay for people
to be using each other and when it's not
okay and what a full friendship involves
the first event that will be hosting is
the free 45 minute webinar which is
about 25 minutes of Mike presenting and
then 20 minutes of open question and
answer and discussion that will be
happening April 25th that's a Tuesday at
12:00 p.m. Central Time very important
so mark your calendar for that later on
that week Saturday April 29th we will be
offering two online intensive seminars
each of these last two hours it's open
to 12 seats maximum so that we can have
a very close and intensive and
interactive learning experience those
are much more focused they go into
greater detail I provide each of the
participants with a recording the slides
and a number of other great resources
those cost forty nine dollars and as I
said there's only 12 seats available for
for each of those two seminars one is at
10 o'clock in the morning again central
time so if you're on the East Coast
coasts or Europe or somewhere else you
wanna make sure you're getting the right
time the other is at 4 p.m. Central Time
all of these are incredible learning
experiences I have been studying
Aristotle teaching Aristotle writing on
Aristotle for two decades now and he's
somebody who I'm particularly interested
in so if you have an interest in
understanding Aristotle or you just want
to understand friendship and
relationships better and you want an
incredibly powerful model with which to
view them then you want to sign up for
either the free webinar or one of the
online seminars you can actually do both
if you want him you'll see links to
those below and if you click and then
scroll down into the video description
you'll see a lot of other great links as
well hope to see you there
[Music]